all right um the pollsters really don't
know what's going to happen tonight
and I have been a defender of polling to
the extent that we understand the
methodology being used you might
remember that the Wright loves to say
the pollsters got it really wrong in
2016. they really didn't the national
popular vote polls said it would be a
three-point margin by which Hillary
would win and Hillary won by a little
over two points in the National popular
vote the the polling was correct but it
did not correctly get the electoral vote
because that came down to very small
margins in a few States so the the the
the general overarching attacks on
polling I'm not big on them they're not
super interesting to me but it is true
that in these particular midterms the
polls may not reflect what's going to
happen tonight there's a very good Daily
Beast article called pollsters have no
effing idea what's going to happen this
election and it says pollsters and
election handicappers are very worried
they could be wrong in decisive ways for
the 2022 midterms now this is a this is
a a
this is a result of two big things
number one
the margins particularly in the Senate
are expected to be very small so when
your most likely outcome is one party
has 51 seats or the other party has 51
seats that's already a range that only
comes down to a couple of seats many of
these races are super close Oz fetterman
is a tie
Walker Warnock is a tie
that's your Senate right there that's
your you know all else being equal those
two races that are ties determine who
controls the Senate so because it's very
close even a small margin of error can
be one party controls the senate or
another party controls the Senate the
other thing that's going on is that
there are growing issues and you can
read the article we'll link to it there
are growing issues with the polling in
two particular ways a lot of the
aggregators like real clear politics are
using a lot of overtly right-wing
pollsters in their uh calculations so
just for example like if you look at
Walker Warnock you see that Trafalgar is
being included in the average Trafalgar
is a known right-leaning pollster so is
that throwing off the numbers that's one
thing and then number two to some degree
you know a lot of people don't pick up
calls from unknown numbers at all
anymore and there is starting to be
aside from the stuff that's done online
for the phone stuff they're starting to
potentially be a sort of self-selection
bias and the people that are interested
in getting on the phone and talking to a
pollster and it can include people who
want to sway the polls in a particular
way okay so the point here is it's
election day ignore the polls but also
the polls really may not be telling us
what's going to happen tonight now
here's the danger of this right-wing
skew to the polls if indeed there is one
you know we're going to look at Clips
later
the the right is telling us they're
going to claim fraud
they're going to do it it's they're
going to claim fraud and one of the ways
they may claim that fraud is by saying
did you see the polls leading up to the
election
you expect us to believe that despite
the polls all these Democrats won now
these are the very same people who in
elections pass say you can't trust the
polls but they are going to weaponize
this right-wing push polling to say look
at the polls and look at what you tell
us was the actual vote that's not
believable it must have been rigged
that's the danger we will have results
in a few hours and then we can put the
polling question aside we talk about it
all the time one of the biggest
contributors to climate change is
deforestation did you know that 15 of
deforestation is due to toilet paper
production alone according to the nrdc
that's why I love our sponsor real paper
real paper makes a sustainable toilet
paper no trees it uses 100 bamboo a
bamboo stock can keep being harvested
indefinitely no deforestation real paper
is certified by the forest Stewardship
Council for responsible harvesting of
the bamboo grass used for their paper
another contributor to climate change
the plastic that the toilet paper comes
wrapped in that's why real paper
involves no plastic packaging and best
of all real paper looks and feels just
like normal traditional toilet paper the
cost is similar it is fantastic on their
website you can do a one-time purchase
or set up an easy recurring subscription
the way that I did my audience gets 30
off your first order plus free shipping
go to realpaper.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman at checkout the link is down
below